now I learned about this over the
weekend and I was just infuriated I'm an
11 year old girl Bella Moscato was told
she had to write a report on her hero
right because she quickly chose
president Trump president United States
someone she's admired since she was in
third grade but her teacher says no
shamed her in front of other students
and warned Bella to choose a different
hero the school district superintendent
telling the Ingram angle the district
does not endorse or condone any
limitation or prohibition upon a
student's choice of the president as a
subject of his or her hero report well
we certainly regret that any student or
parent may have been made to feel
otherwise
Bella's parents Valerie Arthur Moscato
join me now Valerie it's great to have
you guys on what exactly did the
teachers say now when Bella said Trump
was her hero well when she found out
that Trump was her hero she said you're
not allowed to pick Trump he spreads
negativity and he says bad things about
women and I was like Floyd when I heard
that well for for a little girl to have
the poise to not just buckle under the
pressure and actually come home and
Arthur's say mom dad this doesn't seem
right that's what actually gives me a
lot of hope is that your little girl
Arthur said you know something no I'm
not I'm not giving in that's pretty
unusual I have to say well I'm gonna say
this to you my daughter called my wife
during the school day to let my wife
know that and the upsetting thing to me
which I actually found out later was
that not only was my daughter told that
she couldn't do that but she had to go
around and pick somebody else as her
hero when when I was a note to my wife
yes somebody else's hero yeah go around
and go choose go do somebody else's hero
and soon someone in the class also pick
Obama and that was okay yeah that
differently yep
naturally yeah it's a shock so my my my
outburst at the Board of Ed meeting had
a lot to do with that because are you
both well yeah I mean it's just sorry to
interrupt but are you both satisfied
with the school's response here I mean I
tweeted out you're absolutely not
okay so what are you wanting the school
they seem somewhat apologetic I'm just
gonna say I the message that you just
played my wife and I have never heard
yeah
now listen we we love our community and
we we have a lot of support within there
my daughter is one of four kids we have
three boys also the the the school we've
always had very good experiences and
this one is a little sour but Valerie
Valerie how important do you think it is
for parents to speak out
when this kind of stuff happens cuz it
happens all the time how important yeah
I think it's it's extremely important
and I am very grateful and happy that
this story has gotten as big as it has
because this story needs to be told but
you know and you know for I'm very proud
that my daughter knew that that was
wrong and called me and during the
school to tell me this yeah but you
taught her it she's right and if she
didn't tell me this she wasn't doing
Trump is everybody's asking all was
she's still able to do Trump she's able
to do Trump because of me and my husband
not because of the school the district
or the teacher because we raised holy
hell about it and wasn't in school were
object we're gonna we're gonna and we're
gonna try to get the teacher Valerie on
the show and see what she says now that
she's maybe has had some time to reflect
on it and we'll check back with you
because we're gonna
keep tracking these types of stories
across the country thank you both for
joining us and give give our best to
your daughter